today on afterwards Dana Millbank whose
new book is called homo politicus Dana
is a columnist a Washington Post sketch
columnist four times a week Dana thanks
for coming on to talk about homo
politicus pleasure to be here
I've seen people refer to this book as
being in the spirit of an
anthropological excursion or an
adventure you know your excellent
adventure in Washington I think I was
thinking to myself that in terms of
journalism I think of HL Mencken or
Russell Baker maybe even Mark Twain in
terms of the kind of taking a funny look
at Washington and you start with the
idea that this place is called Potomac
land why
well Potomac in the very the words that
the Indians who first lived here used
for it means where the goods are brought
in and when you think about it that's
exactly what Washington is today it's
about sort of who's who's getting the
goods delivered and to on the other side
of things who's getting scalped the
whole idea is I regard it as a rather a
primitive society where there's strange
cases of bartering going on and other
primitive rituals but it's all about
delivering the goods and in the
competition between the two tribes the
Republicans and Democrats to get those
goods but then one of the
interpretations of Potomac land
according to you is the most important
place on earth well of course it is I'm
reminded of the there was a letter
writer to the to the Washington Post a
recently a couple years back who said
that the animals should be treated
better at the zoo here because this is
the zoo in the most important city in
the most important country on earth so
we take ourselves in Washington
extremely seriously and that I think is
is highly amusing to those normal
citizens of other cultures who live say
more than ten miles from here
you know one of the curiosities I think
is that you talk about the rituals that
take place here in Washington and you
have a list of them things like FaceTime
now what exactly is FaceTime well that's
that we're sort of engaging in that
ritual a little bit right now because
we're both
Potomac Men homo politicus in good
standing I hope but that is it's
generally achieved through television it
can be achieved by going to parties of
various social festivals and rituals
around here but it is it's an extremely
important thing for a Potomac man to be
seen and in fact roll-call one of the
the Capitol Hill newspapers actually had
a face time index to determine how much
each of various officials were on
various shows so you know it's not
necessarily the power here doesn't
necessarily mean your ability to pass a
legislation it's to get an audience with
with Tim Russert on Sunday morning or
your friends on Fox well what about
something like now we were talking
earlier about tribes and you said
Republicans and Democrats but you and in
terms of laying out party affiliation
call it fictive kinship line well you
know we do have families here but you
know wives husbands children mothers and
fathers but that's not really how we we
think of our families we think of it in
Potomac man more in terms of who's in
our party you know it brings to mind you
know the most famous inter married
couple Carville and Madeline somewhat of
a strategic alliance there but a
Carville the Democrat Madeline the
Republican both operatives were Republic
exactly exactly and I recount in here
the the story actually on unearthed by a
Bob Woodward of the instance on election
eve how Carville actually had a phone
conversation with his wife which she
promptly relayed to her superiors in the
in the bush-cheney operation we don't
but when you think about the idea of
party affiliation to the rest of America
and to the rest of the world it's taken
pretty seriously but here you don't take
it that seriously
in terms of party affiliation well
because you call it fictive well it's
fictive in the sense that it's not blood
relations that really matter here I mean
people do care presumably about their
children about their spouses but they
really care about is building the string
of their political party that is their
family people go to great lengths to
protect members of their family I mean
consider that until very recently the
the front-runner for the Republican
nomination was a guy been married three
times is known for cross-dressing
supportive of abortion rights and and
and gay rights but Republicans were
embracing him because they thought he
was the guy who could beat Hillary
Clinton coming from the other tribe so
people are willing to tolerate all kinds
of deviancy that's a Potomac man is very
tolerant of deviancy as long as that
person is within his or her own party so
let's stick with the blood theme for a
second here then you have purification
rituals and you mentioned things like
the gridiron dinner or the White House
Correspondents Dinner how's that a
purification ritual
yes well the the president who is as you
and I know as many people believe is the
most important person in all of Potomac
land but that's of course a fiction it's
really the people the strategic advisors
who get that person elected I call them
shaman's like Karl Rove exactly exact
car Ville yes or maybe it'll be mark
Penn if Hillary Clinton prevails it the
names change but those are those are the
most powerful figures but the president
is largely insulated I mean he's
criticized all the time it doesn't have
to take it to his face by and large you
can have press conferences but even
that's not a requirement but once a year
there is this purification ritual it's
called the silly season there's three or
four dinners that the president pretty
much has to attend and he has to go and
sit there while a comedian actually rips
him apart and worse he has to go through
this sort of self-abasement ritual at
the end of it in which he makes fun of
himself this ritual is conducted over
copious amounts of alcohol and then then
they they part ways at the end of this
silly season in the spring and and go
and then from then on go about a very
tense relationship until the next silly
season well you know one of the things
that I enjoyed about the book was the
glossary of Washington ease I guess is
how you would say it and in that
glossary you have things that come to
this whole blood notion for example
bipartisanship
well as you say it's very important to
protect members of your own tribe
Republican or Democrat but when it comes
to bipartisanship you're saying if you
hear that word what should you really
think you should run because that's not
the whole idea is for for people to
assume Americans love to hear people
around the world love to hear the word
bipartisanship it sounds kumbaya what
people really mean by that here is I
need to pick off however many votes from
the other side to ram through this piece
of legislation whether that's one or two
votes in the Senate or a few votes in
the house when somebody says
bipartisanship they're just saying I
need to pick off a guy on the other side
so that's important for those outside of
the land of Homo politicus to understand
alright so again treat me like I'm
coming from outside this land the
strange land Potomac land and I hear the
word frankly mmm again be very afraid
when a person starts off something by
saying frankly they are really
signalling to those of us here that I am
about to say something that is false it
is when when you state that you are
about to be genuine that is just the
moment when you are looking for
something to say to avoid answering a
particular question and what should I
think if I am watching homo políticas in
Potomac land and I hear them say you've
done a great job great job maybe but if
you hear heck of a job that means you've
got about ten days left on your job and
you better find a new one you're going
to be fired are you going to be fired I
mean that did that is the experience of
Mike Brown you may be returned to the
Arabian horse Federation or wherever he
came from before he was plucked out of
obscurity to to join FEMA and when you
look at someone like scooter living and
the serious business of perjury and
going and being sentenced and then
having the president commute the charge
if not pardoned it you see this as some
kind of ritual yes in fact it quite a
barbaric one that there are many of them
here but I compare this to the 15th
century Aztecs it was in those days you
would have your prisoner climb up to the
top of a pyramid where upon his chest
would be ripped open and his
still-beating heart would be yanked out
and and and sacrificed to the gods and
then they dumped the rest of him and his
organs down the other side
the pyramid most people have given up a
human sacrifice this is one of the few
cultures that continues to practice
human sacrifice and the Aztecs believed
it again this would be a sort of a
purification and it works very much the
same way in the Scooter Libby case the
president particularly what the Vice
President was under a great deal of heat
in the Valerie Plame Joseph Wilson case
and ultimately the pressure became so
great that they needed to make this
human sacrifice of Scooter Libby I was
there the day the the jurors came out
after convicting him and the the guy
speaking for the jury said yep he's a
fall guy we knew he was who is standing
up there you know falling on his sword
for for Vice President Cheney was right
there out in the open but it was enough
to sort of appease the the critics or in
this case the the reporters around town
I call them the the Greek chorus but
they were satisfied by that by that
sacrifice of course it's quite easy
because a little while later nudge-nudge
wink-wink the the sentence is commuted
and I'll be willing to wager a large sum
that that the actual pardon comes
through maybe a few days after election
day while sticking with the blood theme
then you talk about just the way that
you just spoke about having the heart
ripped out of somebody now the former
attorney general Alberto Gonzales firing
his chief of staff and that too is a
moment in which you see Washington homo
politicus ripping hearts out what's that
one exactly it's well it's a it's a
again it's a very warlike culture we
have here and I've compared them to the
the early medieval Vikings particularly
the berserkers these are people who
would drink the blood of wolves and
bears they would beat themselves on the
chest and actually inflict injuries on
themselves they would howl they were
believed to be intoxicated but there
were fabulous warriors and they would
kill anything in their path occasionally
killing people on their own side but
these were fearsome warriors and and and
very much feared and that still remains
here in in homo politicus that sort of
an ethos so we we saw poor Alberto
Gonzales a 10
to be the Berserker in his in his own
right and slash and burned those around
him but ultimately his sacrifice was
required as well and obviously many in
Potomac land feel bad about that and
that's why I've agreed to donate a very
small portion of my proceeds to the
Alberto Gonzales legal defense naina the
the glossary is I say I find endlessly
entertaining and in it you have this
notion and I just come out of the
President Bush's own mouth time and
again you're either with us or against
us what does this mean according to dana
Milbank that means you're against us
which is which is a pretty much how the
president speaks if he if he needed to
be saying that he's pretty much telling
the people that he's talking to that
you're against us that this president in
particular has a very binary way of
looking at things but but his rhetoric
is very plain and very sparse but often
there's more to it particularly as
applies to say weapons of mass
destruction
another item i put in the glossary there
is you don't say in potomac land we
didn't find the weapons of mass
destruction you say we found the weapons
of mass destruction program related
activities in hopes that people out
there in the hinterlands will think that
that is one the same thing
well and on a related note here you also
then spring up a banner that says
mission accomplished i went in homo
politicus what do you say mission
accomplished really means well i tried
to look through a whole variety of these
these war phrases ranging from mission
accomplished which means things are
pretty soon about to head south all the
way to the insurgents is in its last
throes which means that we've pretty
much lost the game so you have to you
have to look at each of these things
with a little bit of a prism that will
allow you to understand what's actually
being said so as i said I found the
glossary fascinating but you know there
are people who then say things that come
out of the glossary we just talked about
President Bush but what about someone
like Senator John Kerry who was the
Democrats nominee for president in for
when he says I voted for the 87 billion
dollar appropriation before I voted
against
how does Dana interpret I have
translated that roughly as I am trying
to lose the election that's pretty much
the only thing we can we could come up
with at the time for poor Senator Kerry
when he uttered those words it's it's
not unlike Harry Reid the the Senate
Majority Leader I call it it's almost a
disease that we see here in in Potomac
land that we don't see elsewhere I call
it the Potomac variant Tourette's
syndrome and in Harry Reid's case it's a
tendency to just blurt out very angry
things that come to mind so the the
president is a liar and a loser the
chairman of the Federal Reserve as a
hack the generals in Iraq are
incompetent and then his aides sort of
cringed and they quietly have to walk it
back and he also said we're losing the
war he did say we were losing the war
and many people may agree with that or
certainly had at the time he said it
very careful though that's a there are
certain things you're not supposed to
say here in Potomac land and for for
lesser political figures that could have
been a capital offense but he was able
to survive that so take us through some
other instances of language in
Washington so that if people are
watching the news they can pick up on
what's really meant like what's your
favorite well one that's developed more
recently that's coming out all around us
right now is change and I think it's
important for people around there to
know
that when it when they see our
presidential candidates railing against
Washington and speaking about the need
for change that too is done with sort of
a a little nudge nudge wink wink because
Potomac man knows that these people are
one of us and they wouldn't really do
anything to disrupt the culture of how
the roads the goods are brought in here
in in Potomac land now there are
occasional outsiders so Mike Huckabee
for example is very frightening to
Potomac man because he's really not a
creature of Washington he represents
this very strange force known as
religious conservatives Potomac man
doesn't really understand that he is
nominally Christian or Jewish but in
fact he worships public opinion
that that's his God and his the the
pollsters and strategists are his is
Shaymin so when you have Mike Huckabee
coming in very threatening and they see
him as almost a cannibal invader really
going after the more decent Potomac men
such as a Giuliani or a Mitt Romney so
who are the other primitives besides the
evangelicals who are the primitives out
there that you know sort of beyond the
great wall that surrounds the Beltway
yes well everybody is I think that
that's important to note and I've sort
of developed homo politicus it's it's
not unlike the Varna caste system that
we that the that India has had for
centuries and millennia in fact and of
course at the top of that you have these
these these shaman's these high priests
who are able to understand and
manipulate public opinion with their the
various rituals below that you'll have
the the warrior class which is most of
the the political figures of course the
actual elected officials being below the
shaman's or strategist then you'll have
sort of the the other parts every all
the rest of us who participate in the in
the political industrial complex here
and the lower classes sort of the
untouchables as people who live here but
are not involved in politics and they
are largely invisible to Potomac man and
they are of course the majority the ABC
news used to refer to what they call the
gang of 500 the belief being that
they're only about 500 people in Potomac
land who actually run the show very few
of them are actually members of Congress
for example but these are the chatterers
and this is a when you look at the whole
metropolitan or area this is several
million people here but it's really only
500 people who are visible to Potomac
man and all the rest are untouchable so
when we say who are the barbarians it's
pretty much everybody well what's
interesting to me is then you identify
Tom DeLay as a true important person in
Potomac Lee and even though he wasn't
Speaker of the House then he has tit
with Speaker of the House but you say
Tom DeLay was
the puppetmaster making things happen so
how does Tom DeLay the exterminator the
hammer get to be this powerful figure
Tom DeLay is a I think really the
pinnacle of what Potomac man is in fact
I dedicated the book to Tom DeLay for
all the things he has done
for journalism over the past decade or
so and he too sadly is in need of some
some Legal Defense Fund help right now
but he really was extraordinarily
successful and I think says a lot about
Potomac man because here he was the
number three figure than the number two
figure in the house but in fact he was
more powerful than anybody in that
Capitol he installed a Denny Hastert as
the speaker more or less
and he really determined what was going
to happen I think that just in the same
way that Karl Rove was really the most
important person in the White House
arguably him or Dick Cheney
it wasn't the president just like it
wasn't the Speaker of the House so
that's that's very common and delays of
course also an important Potomac land
figure because he is such a fine warrior
and you know we have obviously the
hammer fits very well into the the way
that I view Potomac man he has a war
name there was of course Katherine
Harris who actually had war paint on her
face there's Howard wait a second when I
say I gotta stop you there because
there's something in the in the book
Homa políticas about Katherine Harris
that anything yes because I found just
like startlingly funny which was the
ring tone story yes well it let's let's
back up to get to that point Katherine
Harris an extraordinary figure was once
in some sort of a a traffic infraction
here in Potomac land and jumped out
wearing a Taekwondo outfit he ever knew
exactly what she was going to do she ran
for the Senate unsuccessfully she held
one event at an airport hanger almost
nobody showed up and she was asked what
happened should well a tree fell on the
hanger that we were supposed to have the
event in the local papers looked into it
there was no tree there was no other
hanger
there were no people and so there became
this this sort of I called her one of
the deviants that were tolerated so well
by members of her own party but it got
to the point that even one of her
campaign managers programmed the
Exorcist tune to play in his cell phone
when his boss actually called and
another one of these folks is Helen
Chenoweth of Idaho and he described her
as having a baked in for was it
endangered salmon you guys think why
would you do that yes and and she sadly
now the late Helen Jenna the but she
ushered into Potomac Land the black
helicopter crowd and and she was one of
the original rebels of 1994 and and
really left her mark years is one of the
great warriors now we don't we're quite
egalitarian and Potomac land the the
Warriors do not have to be a men in fact
we have a large category of the Amazon
warriors I believe who descend from
those from a Greek mythology who cut off
one of their breasts so they would be
able that are able to fire the bow and
arrow and then you have people like Bill
Jefferson the congressman from Louisiana
who will put the goods on this being
Potomac land in the freezer yes and I I
think it's a he deserves some credit for
being as open about it as he was and
what I described it is the goods
it's called mocha and this is a comes
from Melanesia they have their what they
call big men these are the leaders
they're not hereditary titles they're
not elected they become big men by
giving out mocha or tribute to their
various followers who then become loyal
to them this is very much the way
congressmen behave with lobbyists and
others they they are the lobbyists
support them in terms of their campaigns
and donations the lobbyists there
therefore becomes the big man and the
the member of Congress will will do his
bidding very similar so William
Jefferson was I think just more open
about it than others he was
unfortunately
filmed by the FBI putting a a suitcase
full of $100,000 in in marked bills into
the trunk of his Lincoln Towncar
his house was raided by the FBI they did
find 90 thousand of those dollars in his
freezer
disguised as leftovers and little foil
containers but in a way he isn't he
really doing what others do on a smaller
basis so I think he gets some credit for
being a true Potomac man the same way do
cunningham who has fallen sadly from
power here in town a congressman who
actually drew up a mocha list a bribery
list if you will that said this is how
much it will cost for this particular
earmark to be inserted you'll have to
buy me a boat if you want me to do this
or a house for this I thought that's
very efficient why not I actually have a
price list like when you're going into
McDonald's and that it's a way to make
the Potomac economy far more efficient
well let me give you two other
characters that come to play in home Oh
politicus one is Bob Dornan and the
other is Bob trafficking yes these are
old-timers I tried to to focus on the
more recent in this millennium of the
last seven now eight years but of course
to understand the the Potomac way of
thinking I think it was important to go
back to b1 Bob Dornan one of the
original great great warriors great
berserkers and of course congressman
traffic and who would end every speech
on the House floor by saying beam me up
ultimately he was beamed right out of
Potomac land and of course we miss him
still well your eyes think to myself
some of these folks are so eccentric I
don't believe that they could function
in any other business in America I think
most people would think that person's
kind of nuts but you're saying they're
just part of the scene here in fact we
encourage nuttiness we absolutely do
encourage nuttiness
I mean cert be fair I mean there are
certain things that go beyond the
boundary but but generally we will
tolerate deviancy and that is if you're
a Democrat you will tolerate pretty much
anything
on your side and Republicans will do the
same thing on there so I think a
terrific example of this is a
congressman former congressman now Don
Sherwood family values republican very
high marks from Christian Coalition and
others then it emerged that he had been
having an affair with a young woman 40
years his junior he was of course
married at the time and still is I
believe but then she filed a lawsuit
saying that he had been beating her and
she had to run into the bathroom of
their their love nest and she had to
call 911 out he very quietly settled the
lawsuit this was not looking good but in
Potomac land you have to rally around
your own so the the Republican tribe
rallied around this man in fact
President Bush actually went up to
campaign for him in the last days of the
2006 election gave a rather impassioned
defense of Don Sherwood in fact it was
in the middle of what the president had
declared national character counts week
and in fact I believe that the
congressman's wife and daughter was
sitting there while the president was
speaking along so is this this is Kabuki
theater yeah there's a there's a large
amount of Kabuki theater going on here -
I've got a whole section on on that in
the book as well you know one of the
whole idea about these eccentrics is
that when it comes to delivering the
goods in Potomac land that if you're
involved with mating it's absolutely
essential then to prove to the young
woman whose affections you desire that
you can put an earmark in and get
legislation done for her and you say
most often the politicians are meeting
with the lobbyists yes it's quite common
it's it's really transactional love and
Potomac land like everything else is
really all about bringing in the goods
and it's transactional I I compared it
to some some tribes primitive tribes
with it there's a bride price so if
you're you get the bride but you have to
hand over a few head of cattle very much
the same thing here but instead of
handing over to cattle you you hand over
earmarks and this is a is quite common
to to see important members of Congress
pairing off with
lobbyists now it's it it should be known
that frequently a powerful Potomac man a
member of Congress will feel that his
own power is has some sort of an
aphrodisiac power on other people while
this may be true for say lobbyists or
others who are clearly among homo
politicus not true for sort of the
common person I tell the story of a
young congressman in here who was at a
bar in Georgetown offered to give his
congressional lapel pin to this woman
presumably to impress her she was not
impressed and fact made off with his
lapel pin and a major security incident
ensued you know the oddity of this is
that there are taboos in Potomac land so
what are the taboos what can't you do
well the taboos it's hard to say because
there are so many things that in fact
you can do and you often don't know
you've crossed a taboo until you've
reached one and even then there are
certain things you can do I compare
Potomac man to the the tribe where that
the taboo is against cutting your hair
but if you eat a man first that is said
to ward off the ill effects from having
your hair cut but so Potomac man will go
through all sorts of things like this
that the most famous would be John
McCain who's very much in the news now I
was doing quite well in the 2000
campaign and then he spoke of agents of
intolerance talking about Falwell and
Robertson these are sacred cows it is
taboo to to defame them particularly for
a Republican running for the for the
Republican nomination he has done the
equivalent of eating several men to
overcome this taboo that he has violated
he went to speak it at their
universities he has you know been trying
to prostrate himself on their altars
still hasn't quite worked as you can see
why why Mike Huckabee is doing so well
here but there's a whole bunch of taboos
raging to the fairly minor when
congresswoman McKinney struck the
Capitol
police officer with her cell phone
that's a no-no don't ill he'd gotten
away with all kinds of crazy utterances
but striking the police officer with a
cell phone out of a job not allowed all
right we're going to take a break and
come back with dana Milbank his book is
called the strange and scary tribes that
run our government home Oh politicus
it's published by doubleday afterwards
and several other c-span programs are
available for download as podcast more
with dana Milbank and juan williams in a
moment sunday on book TV Shelby Steele
says Barack Obama can't win the US
presidency in his book about man the
scholar of race relations and
multiculturalism argues that voters may
be more interested in the historical
implications of an Obama win than in the
candidates actual policies Shelby Steele
Sunday at 10:15 a.m. and 4:15 p.m.
Eastern on book TV on c-span
2
afterwards with dana Milbank and juan
williams continues we're back for
afterwards with dana Milbank his new
book is called homo politicus dana of
course is the washington sketch
columnist with the washington post four
times a week you're a busy man I am a
busy man and it's not getting any easier
this election season by the way if you
know people reading this book you know
people will describe it as satire if is
there but it some some of it's just
outright funny just humorous and if you
someone came to see you on the street
said Dana what's the funniest story
you've come across how long have you
been in Washington dozen years now so
what's the funniest most absurd story in
houma politicus you'd say well I I'll
tell you it was when I was sitting down
with Jack Abramoff he now disgraced
lobbyists he was a good source of mine
told me what was going on in the
Congress what was going on in the White
House he was also a restaurateur this is
what he did with some of his ill-gotten
gains we were sitting at his fancy
restaurant signatures I'd like to claim
that I paid the bill that I'm not sure I
have the records to prove it and he was
about to open up a new restaurant a
kosher a Jewish deli and but he had
something very exciting to tell me he
said his Deli is going to be the first
in the world to serve a kosher Pig bacon
pork pork pork is not kosher by large
but he said he had located a breed of
swine in Asia that had cleft hooves and
chewed its cud and therefore was going
to qualify as kosher so you could have
ham sandwiches and and bacon and all
kinds of good stuff
I got obviously quite excited about this
and went back to my office to research
it turned out not to be true as with so
much else about Jack Abramoff so that
would to me was the the epitome of
Potomac man now in fact let's continue
with Jack Abramoff because Jack Abramoff
is well you can say a conceit or a he is
a central player in homo politicus
because you analogize Jack Abramoff to
what you call Melanie's big man the man
as you described in the first segment
who showers people with gifts in his
case things like gifts to the Verizon
Center the skyboxes or
golf trips which he gave to someone else
we've been talking about Tom DeLay or
trips to go to casinos and gambling
boats I think he owns some gambling
boats down in Florida he was the very
best at the at the the way at bringing
the goods in as his done in Potomac land
he was the biggest of the big men and
there others would you know have nickel
and dime treats for people at
restaurants but he had the golfing trips
to Scotland
he had set up all these elaborate
charities there was seemingly nothing
that he couldn't do I one of my favorite
things was how he set up an
international think tank on the on the
Delaware Shore turned out to be staffed
entirely by a lifeguard in a I believe
it was a yoga artist so there's almost
nothing that the Jack Abramoff couldn't
do what why would he do that that was a
Dodge wasn't that that was to cover up
yes they were looking for ways to to
hide the the money that was taken from
Indian tribes back some hundred million
dollars worth of it but but even that
don't you think is really the essence of
homo politicus what stealing from other
tribes but that's what's done here
except it's other Americans now well the
most dangerous thing that dana Milbank
does in this book is go after one of
your colleagues at the Washington Post
Bob Woodward who you identify kind of
again as quintessential homo politicus
tell me about Bob Woodward well one I
speak of him with reverence and of
course he I think the it was the the
Weekly Standard put it best after one of
his books about the president and the
White House that the the President Bush
gives him all the time he needs because
this is Bob Woodward's town and the rest
of us are just living at it and it does
it does sort of show you much about the
hierarchy and many people outside of
Potomac land might assume that George
Bush is a more powerful man than Bob
Woodward and they would of course be
wrong about that
so I wrote about the very important he's
in a section I call the the Greek Horus
that's all of us in the media they are
the Greek chorus you know that the play
is going on but they're constantly
interrupting to sing and dance and draw
attention
themselves and that's what we do but he
is is by far the most prominent chorus
leader in town and it's very important
to have the proper care and feeding of
Bob Woodward and he's written three
books about the Bush presidency all
terrific sellers and the the first one
quite flattering got a lot of access
second one also quite good access quite
flattering the third one they decided
you know what we're not going to play
ball we're not going to cooperate with
Bob Woodward and that book turned out
very badly for the president do not
anger the guy not exactly that's exactly
what we're talking about here and also
quintessential Homa politicus of
Washington would be someone like Vice
President Cheney mm-hmm now I don't even
know where to start if you wanted to do
humor on the vice president shooting
people the vice president saying things
about weapons of mass destruction needs
to sort of pick the the right category
to to place these people in but I
decided to put him in the mythology a
category in Potomac land like other
cultures has certain founding myths that
make us here believe that that we are
important and and worthwhile and he is
one of the great creator of myths in
Potomac land and you know as well as
we've already mentioned the last throes
the the facts that that Saddam Hussein
had in fact reconstituted nuclear
weapons the fact that it was pretty well
established that Assad was saying had a
hand in the September 11th attacks a
wide range of things and Cheney has been
particularly effective at using the
Sunday morning talk shows as a way to
tell his stories to spin his myths to
the to the public at large and so he
really is our our sort of our native
storyteller but you know there are a lot
of people who believe it that's exactly
right that wouldn't that and that's what
what myths are all about I mean there
are some cultures as I wrote and
book believe that the Sun rises and
falls because it's the sun goddess
carrying her torch across the sky she
dips it in the ocean that's the Sun down
you get the Ember she crawls under the
world and does it again the next day
people believe this and here people
believe I think it was 75% of our
countrymen believe that Iraq was
involved in the September 11th attacks
it's not funny because it's true this is
not this is not satire this is normal
yes it's very--it's sometimes it is very
difficult to to know to satirize people
in this town who are very quite couldn't
and adapt at doing that themselves now
someone who is constantly skewered by
the Jay Leno's David Letterman's Jon
Stewart's is Teddy Kennedy the senator
from Massachusetts but he actually
doesn't get rough treatment your book no
I gave him a little bit of a treatment
for example one of his speeches on the
on a Senate floor where he was talking
about some nuclear a stockpile
stewardship program taking care of the
but he called the the stockpile
stewardess program an unfortunate
direction to head in for that man but I
did have a bit of a fun with his son who
was you know famously crashed his car
and tactic in Patrick congressman from
Rhode Island crashes car into a Capitol
police barricade in the middle of the
night slurring his speech and alleging
that he was late for a vote quite late
in fact since the Congress was not it
was not in session but but he did play
the the drug-rehab card which is a very
common way to overcome a transgression
or taboo now you know we're talking
about people who are examples of home
and politicus and you have one prime
example here about Ari Fleischer who was
the president's press secretary and aeri
Fleischer again talking about weapons of
mass destruction here we come back to
myths and Vice President Cheney says
that really is the burden of people who
don't believe their weapons of mass
destruction I believe here I'm close to
quoting and saying it's the burden is on
them to tell us where these weapons of
mass
in our since they tell us there are no
weapons of mass it this is this will
make you stop and think and then go
crazy yes you can't think too long
it's very perilous I know you've sat
through many of those White House
briefings very perilous to think too
much in those but I chronicled the
transition from Ari Fleischer to Scott
McClellan who himself had to become a
the victim of a human sacrifice when he
went out to defend falsely Karl Rove and
in scooter libby and then and then
through to a through to tony snow so i
i've traced all of those but but in all
cases the you know once again this is
not about transmitting information this
is about this is entertainment and
theater for potomac man well so what
goes on in the White House press room is
to be described as ritual it is sort of
a ritual and I describe the press corps
they're very much like people outside of
Potomac land might regard their high
school you know the you have sort of
this star television correspondence up
front they're the the football captain
or the cheerleading captain you've got
the wire reporters who sort of the
student government president then you've
got the the newspaper correspondents
they're sort of the the geeks and
mathletes and then you get you know
further back to the regional
correspondents they know eventually you
wind up in shop class and nothing comes
of it there's no real information or
content no well occasionally there is
but it would be strictly by accident or
by error that's uh it is it is strictly
a place for Potomac man to engage in his
uh his warlike behaviors so how does
news get made well as I say generally it
occurs by accident when somebody
inverted Li says something that they
weren't supposed to say but but
generally the news that is made is
occurs in the news media because this is
where the warring tribes fight it out so
aggression and that's one of the
sections in the book aggression is is a
dance
is a dance here in Potomac land so give
me some examples of aggression well the
the places is rampant with them but to
stick with the sort of news media theme
each tribe or party will attempt to
co-opt journalists towards its cause so
that they can essentially be a
mercenaries you know for their
aggressive tendencies so you know at one
extreme we have Jeff Gannon
I believe it was GOP USA at least until
it turned out he was also performing as
an actual prostitute as opposed to a
political one or the Armstrong Williams
a case which I wrote about here as well
and they're there of course a journalist
on either side who can be enlisted to
the cause here but aggression is you
know it's the fundamental way of how
Potomac man exists and we've talked
about Tom DeLay another great Potomac
warrior Donald Rumsfeld and we I'm sure
you miss him almost as much as like we
do we do and what about someone though
you people take seriously like : Powell
well Colin Powell it and it's it's not
all that well-known but in fact he was a
subject to human sacrifice how's that
well many people assume that cabinet
officers are powerful people in fact
they are manipulated by young
twentysomething aides who work in the
White House again a common misconception
of the cabinet member would be stronger
than those other people but I recounted
in here in fact a delightful anecdote
dug up by my colleague at the post Karen
DeYoung about how : Powell was when he
in fact retired or stepped down in fact
he was told he had no choice but to do
that apparently I was told to draft his
resignation letter and then when he made
a typo in at the White House sent it
back to him to fix a typo in his
resignation letter so that you know they
wanted to have it out sort of a
self-immolation saying I'm going to take
myself out of this when in fact he was
he was being sacrificed even
an extremely powerful and beloved figure
such as that and for women you know we
talk so much about the men here I think
maybe as you said Helen Chenoweth now
gone might be an exception maybe if we
stop and think about Kathleen Katherine
Harris and another woman but in general
women escape in this humorous treatment
except for someone you call Amazon who's
that which is a considerable body of
people here and I spent some time with
writing about Nancy Pelosi who has used
her worrying skills to great effect in
the house and in Senate Senator Barbara
Boxer from California in fact as she I
was she was kind enough to inadvertently
blurb the book for me she says this is
taking trash journalism to to new
heights so I've taken that quote out of
context and put it on the back of the
book but oh yes and I didn't actually
put Hillary Clinton in the category of
of an Amazon warrior I think she's more
of a revenge killer and you know when
you think about the tribes it in this
case it's really the the the bush and
the Clintons have been representing
their tribe in a series of revenge
killings I've compared it to some still
existing primitive tribes in in South
America so we can see Bill Clinton
defeat of the the first bush being
revenged avenged in 1994 and then
ultimately when bush came back and
defeated Clinton's air and now we see an
attempt of resurgence of the the Clinton
clan and if she wins now that would be
seen as a revenge killing and then you
have things with younger women and I
like this young woman who was blogging
about her sexual escapades up on Capitol
Hill this is real this is not satire you
can't make this that Jessica Cutler The
Washingtonian she caused quite a stir
here a couple years back writing in
lurid detail about her her escapades but
I think what distinguishes that was not
necessarily the Lord detail although
that was a
enough to make you squeamish but but the
way people reacted
she had outed one man a staffer on the
hill and although it was so obscure that
nobody ever were would have heard his
name but now we all know the name Robert
Steinberg because what did he do he went
and he sued her and they went through
discovery and then their lawsuits now
mentioned all the allegations all over
again so it took it out of the obscurity
of the blog world and made it literally
a federal case and I think that gets to
the Potomac man's need as we're talking
earlier for face time for recognition
and for exposure in other words he
wasn't stupid he was intentionally
trying to draw attention to himself I'm
trying to give him credit for that it
art it is possible along the lines of
sexual behavior then we have the case of
David Vitter the congressman from
Louisiana and you also have the Senator
Larry Craig from Idaho
now Vitter doesn't get into too much
trouble he's not asked to resign but
Craig is pressured by his own trying the
Republicans to get out although he never
does what's the difference yes it I
describe this is quite an elaborate
public fertility ritual that would occur
in a place such as an airline terminal
and yes the the homosexuality taboo is
particularly strong for in the in the
Republican tribe I also write about Mark
Foley earlier and he was drummed out
very quickly so now probably of course
was accused of coming on to pages the
young people yes yeah so it had the yes
they the effect of it being homosexual
and underage so he was drummed out very
quickly Larry Craig seemed to be
suffering the same effect but I don't
know if you noticed I think this is
relevant to a putana culture and that is
that recently they had to have a Senate
election to replace Trent Lott who was
retiring and for the moment everybody
was being nice to Larry Craig again
because they needed his vote and so even
a man who has violated taboo like that
who was basically some sort of internal
exile that he was facing for a more
munted had returned so let's talk a
little bit about dana Milbank where were
you born I was born in Long Island New
York and went to school where went to
school and Yale up in Connecticut and
although I did not study anthropology I
got those degrees from Google and
Wikipedia and then you went what did you
study at you political science political
science
yes prepared me for my study of Potomac
man and I I did purchase a pith helmet
although I left it in the office well
you don't need it today and then where
did you go where'd you begin your
journalistic with the I was with the
Wall Street Journal for eight years and
then I covering covering this town a
little bit but I was also in London for
a couple of years as a foreign
correspondent and when I came to
Washington after that I felt I was still
a foreign correspondent in this very
strange land and that that was sort of
the the genesis of this and so when did
you start the Washington sketch count
that started in about 2000 at late 2004
so you've been doing it for but we think
about several years now it covered the
Bush White House before that now the the
strange thing about this is you know to
start we were talking about sort of your
antecedents which would be people like
HL Mencken people you know I think lots
of people would remember not only Menken
but others Russell Baker at the New York
Times for example doing humor columns
but they seem to have gone out of style
in this era you'd be the exception most
people turn for humor to the likes of
Jon Stewart or Leno and Letterman why is
it that we don't see more satire more
satirical writing well I mean first it's
an honor to be mentioned even in the
same sentence with with with people like
that and I think it is it's
extraordinary how important a Colbert or
Stewart is right now with what they call
fake news and that's something I don't
quite understand because actual real
news is you don't need to gild the lily
here it's pretty absurd it is absolutely
that way and I think what happens is a
lot of people look at what hat what's
happening in Potomac land and they get
angry they say this is disgraceful and
you know that and I think people get
riled up and and that's
and that fuels the the partisan war and
aggression that that goes on here I find
it's more effective to just take a step
back and yes of course there we see
things everyday that that make us angry
but rather than building up the bile and
the in the blood pressure it seems to me
it's probably more effective to look at
it in a lighter way and just how very
strange these normal everyday event
events really are well I'm thinking back
you know historically if you look at
Megan he's making fun of President
Hoover during a very crazy time
obviously the depression but he's also
making fun of President Roosevelt mhm
and Roosevelt humor obviously his time
extends from Great Depression through
World War and so here you are making fun
of people at a time when you know
President Bush would stamp there and say
we are engaged in the serious business
of the war on terror are you ever
scolded by readers well well every day
hundreds of times but and it is a dicey
business that I mean the example of
Menken that lost his popularity during
the Second World War and there during
those serious times so certainly things
can be can be taken too far and I
remember the time after 2001 when the
aforementioned Ari Fleischer advised
people to watch what you say and there
was a chilling he advised journalists
not about anybody in general yes or
we're the ones doing a lot of the saying
right but yeah this was after a
particular inflammatory remark by Bill
Maher but in it I don't believe that
remark had a chilling effect but there
was a chilling effect going on there now
and thank God we're out of that because
serious things can be going on but
people should still be able to speak so
who do you read like for humor now I
would think Maureen Dowd at times can be
pretty funny
would you agree oh I adore her writing
and you know I if I have a model in this
business it's it's the light merry
McGrory who but now she was not a
humorist she was more of someone who
would take you inside the theater of the
absurd and just do the story you
actually turn a you know a cynical eye
to the goings-on I what but what I tried
to do is actually go and see these
events with my own eyes see them hear
them and smell them frequently but as
opposed to just sitting back in the
armchair and popping off about it I
don't think that's very useful but if
you can actually get in there and look
at the people in the way they're
behaving I think you can learn a lot and
of course the humors a byproduct of it
because you know I guarantee you if you
go into a hearing on the in the the
Rayburn house office building no matter
what the subject you're going to see
people behaving in aberrant and bizarre
ways no matter what the subject is well
do you think that in fact to get to
Washington run for elected office in
this day and age you've got to be
something of an aberrant psychology I
mean you got to be willing to do odd and
strange things in order to separate
yourself out and put yourself through
that what can be an extraordinarily
tiring and difficult exercise of winning
elected off you don't have to be
aberrant to win office in the first
place you have to be Everett to stay
here and to want to stay here in this
town and that is because you're quickly
sucked into this need to to appease the
big men and ultimately to become a big
man yourself I mean isn't that why
people get elected to Congress not to
serve in Congress but ultimately to go
through the revolving door and make lots
of money you know in fact Gary Trudeau
who does doonesbury had a cartoon just
the other day Sunday comic strip in
which he just went through the names of
senators who were now lobbyists and it's
unbelievable what a roll call it is
yesterday and that's sort of the ascent
of Potomac man here you you know there's
the lowly staffer there's the
back-bencher in Congress works his way
up to leadership and then at the very
pinnacle of his power is when he is the
lobbyist because those are the big men
they're the big men ed of it more so
than let's say presidents who get paid
100
Plus to give a talk for the Japanese
well true enough a president can after
he leaves office become a very big man
after he leaves office yes it is it can
be done that way too now when you look
at the families people tend not to make
fun of the children and thinking here
about Jenna and Barbara Bush it's almost
like not allowed to make fun although
they can do pretty absurd things
themselves yes I tiptoed around that a
bit in this book but I wrote about the
the Potomac socializing culture
everything here is broken up by tribe
where you worship where you send your
kids to school
what bars you go to so the young
Democrats will be at Stetsons on you
street young Republicans like Jenna and
Barbara would hang out at a smooth point
in Georgetown and in fact the list to
get in there while people are standing
out there in lines was very much a young
Republican list so it determines your
family it determines your upbringing and
education it determines your socializing
that your tribe your party is your
family and who does the best job for the
young people who don't read dana Milbank
don't read newspapers don't watch the
news but do watch jay leno or do watch
Jon Stewart or Stephen Colbert who do
you think of those folks is the best
satirist on Washington goodness it much
of it occurs past my my bedtime and as I
say I've got enough to see here with
without people actually figuring out
jokes rather than looking at the the
actual humor in the daily events but I
think but certainly Jon Stewart is the
one who was set the pace now and any
white why Stewart setting these pace
because it's the young audience he
relates to the younger audience or do
you think it works for people of all
ages or do you think it's just that
we're in a TV age well certainly we're
in a TV age it certainly works for all
audiences but I also feel that he's most
effective because he's not his Lance
isn't very sharp
I think he's has a lighter touch and
he's not playing in a character like a
Colbert he has more freedom to Rove and
I think that is
that worked well for him if they can
ever get back in business so now just
the other day I read where the fellow
who plays Ali G and he used he did a
real odd thing where he would come to
Washington and he would get these big
men to sit down on the principle that
they're being interviewed they want face
time as you call it and then he would go
off on some absurd riff you know saying
stupid things to them and it took
forever before they realize wait a
second I'm being goofy done this is why
oh absolutely and then of course in
Borat he was able to get Bob Barr the
former congressman to eat a piece of
cheese which he then said was from his
wife's breast milk which I thought was
brilliant and particularly brilliant for
Bob Barr because he wants
during he was an impeachment manager for
Bill Clinton he spoke about how the
flames of hedonism are licking at our
culture and of course licking was a bad
word for Bob Barr because he was quite
famous for licking the whipped cream off
the buzz among
some some women at a party as a
fundraiser so there's a real pattern
here well I mean but there is so much
absurdity I was thinking of a former
attorney General John Ashcroft
and the statue with the display of more
than cleavage actual naked breasts and
the objections to the point of covering
it yes they covered up the statue with
it with a large drape and then why is
that taboo well it wasn't really taboo I